is that any better any here at the back
is that okay heads nodding okay that's a
good sign well thank you very much for
coming I the way I've done these in the
past is to briefly explain the
chronology of the book what it's about
then explain how I came to be involved
in it and why I've done the book and
then read a few sections if that's okay
and then take some questions I hope
that's all right the story in the book
essentially starts a few months before
the 1972 Munich Olympics during the
summer of 1972 it starts in in Rome in a
sweet Piazza there where a group of
senior Palestinians were meeting they
were just meeting up for a coffee to
discuss world events and success of
their latest mission to Italy to obtain
weapons and they were reading in
national newspapers in Italy and they
saw a little paragraph about the Olympic
Games and the paragraph just said that
the Palestinians had written to the
Olympic Committee asking to be allowed
to have a Palestinian delegation of the
1972 Munich Games and nobody had
responded to their letters and this was
essentially the the origins of the
attack that became known as the the
Munich Massacre the Palestinians decided
they were going to launch their own
attack at the games or they were going
to make their own entrance at the games
and they began planning how they would
launch an attack on the Israeli
delegation there just a few months later
initially they had very few problems
organizing the attack they managed to
find a somebody to lead it and a deputy
for him then they managed to get
volunteers people would just very eager
to volunteer in fact one of them
apparently was was begging them was in
tears when he was initially refused the
chance to take part they had very few
problems getting the weapons that they
would need into Germany despite the fact
that the the games were coming up the
security was very slack they took the
weapons in through the main Munich
Airport and
the Palestinian later brought in
grenades in his hand luggage so it had
very few problems and quite frankly the
Germans didn't really make it very hard
for them in because of the memories of
the the Holocaust and the Nazi period
the Germans kept security at the Olympic
Games in 1972 very lights they had
security guards dressed up in pretty
blue outfits and armed with
walkie-talkies and they sent these guys
out to God athletes from around the
world the Palestinians used this very
much to their advantage really they
gathered outside the perimeter fence of
the Olympic Village where which was
where all the athletes were living from
around the world they gathered there
early on the morning of September the
fifth up until that point the games had
gone spectacularly well the Germans
really had achieved what they wanted to
achieve they've been hoping that the
world would see the new Germany if you
like this new country which had shown
itself of all its Nazi past and was
really showing itself to the world anew
they'd called the games the games of
peace and joy and they really had gone
very well mark swits at obviously
dominated headlines Olga Korbut people
might remember her little elfin figure
over the gymnastics floor and the
Germans really were thinking that the
games would get carry on in the same in
the same vein and they would go really
well for the rest of it anyway the
Palestinians gathered outside the
Olympic Village early in the hours as I
say they just came to the perimeter
fence it was just a six-foot fence there
was no barbed wires just topped with
little cones and some germ some saw some
American athletes were actually
returning to their accommodation at the
same time as she helped the Palestinians
over the fence
totally unwittingly after he said they
thought the Palestinians were just
another group of athletes who'd been out
partying and tragically contributed in
some small way to the the success of the
palestinian operation really the
palestinians climbed over they were
helped over they helped the americans
over and then they ran to the building
at number 31 connelly Strasse which
was the building housing the Israeli
delegation they arrived there they
battered their way in and in the first I
mean really within the first few moments
of the attack they were the first
Israeli casualties to Israelis moshe
weinberg and yosef romano were hit with
bullets and both died within really
within an hour of the initial attack it
was an absolute tragedy I mean the the
Palestinians have since claimed that
they feel they went in they're not
planning to commit any violent acts they
thought they could go in there they
could have launched a peaceful operation
but I find it's very difficult to
believe myself because they seem to have
deliberately gone after the heavy guys
the weight lifters the wrestlers people
they must have known weren't going to
just submit peacefully or willingly to
their their demands so two israelis were
were killed in the initial attack
another nine were taken hostage several
others managed to escape they broke
windows and climbed out another group
managed to barricade themselves inside
their room but nine were taken hostage
they were put in one room and the corpse
of one of the israelis was put in the
middle as a sort of warning and some
perverse warning to them about what
would happen should they dare to try to
escape so nine were being held hostage
the Germans then became aware of what
was going on their initial response was
as inept as their response throughout
the whole attack they a few unarmed
officers went down there security
officials and just begged the
Palestinians to give up they just said
you can't do this this is our this is
our German games this is our chance to
show the world we're not Nazis anymore
but I mean obviously the Palestinians
weren't when interested in just giving
in they were fully committed they were
well-armed well-trained and they had
absolutely no intention of surrendering
they issued their demands which were for
the release of over 200 prisoners who
were being held in Israeli jails and a
few who were being held in German ones
as well
and this was then conveyed back by the
German authorities to go to my ear the
Israeli prime minister and the rest of
the Israeli government and gold who had
no doubt she would
used from the very outset to even
consider doing a deal with the
terrorists or giving it in any way she
felt that this would immediately
encourage other terrorist attacks that
if she gave him that time then she would
have forgiven again in the future so she
refused to give in and she basically
said to the Germans it's up to you it's
on German soil
we'll help as much as we can but it's up
to you the Germans to resolve this and
save our people so the Germans began
negotiating with the terrorists they had
no idea what they were doing they'd
never had to do anything like it they
didn't really understand the background
they didn't understand what the
terrorists wanted and they didn't really
understand how fanatical they were they
just thought they were like criminals
and they could appeal to them or offer
them a deal and that they would give in
there seems to have been some sort of
threats to the Palestinians by other
Palestinian militants that if the
Palestinian terrorists involved in this
attack gave in and surrendered they
would then be tracked down and killed
themselves by other Palestinian
terrorists so this made it almost
inevitable that they were going to see
the day through that they were really
going to try and get their aims
fulfilled and this is what they did they
initially they extend the deadlines that
they've issued initially they'd said
that unless the Palestinian prisoners in
Israel were released by nine o'clock
then they would execute some of their
hostages that deadline passed because
some Arab negotiators were brought in
and they managed to persuade them to
extend this deadline but then they set
other deadlines and I think we can only
begin to imagine the the torment of some
of the relatives who were then waking to
the news to discover that not only were
they discovering that their relatives
were their fathers their husbands
brothers etc were being held hostage but
they they only had minutes or a couple
of hours to go until the deadline where
they were supposed to be executed it was
absolutely terrible for them I mean you
can imagine I hope to some degree just
how their world fell apart
you had people waking up in Israel in
Holland across Europe and in America as
well relatives of the Israelis who are
being held hostage waking and
discovering this news from you
and while it was a very obviously a very
private tragedy for them it was also
very public one because many of them
heard the news on the radio and the
television news of the seat was soon
being broadcast by ABC in this country
live with Jim Mackay and Peter Jennings
I didn't if people remember this
coverage that went on on and on it
seemed to go in America the the live
coverage it was being broadcast and the
relatives were watching it just as other
members of the public were watching it
so it was very public and a very private
tragedy as well and it was left as I say
to the Germans to try and resolve in
their own inimitable way the Israelis
believed that they the Germans had the
necessary expertise that they had the
hostage negotiation tactics necessary
but they really didn't the Germans had
no idea initially the first real attempt
they made to release the hostages was to
dress up some German police officers as
chefs with the complete with the hat and
the whole outfit and unfortunately
forgotten the policeman was still
wearing their rather obvious policeman
boots terrorists had no intention of
letting the chef's come near the
building the German police sent them up
loaded with platters of food thinking
that somehow they'd be able to get into
the building and overpowered the
terrorists with their bare hands the
Palestinians were having none of it they
weren't stupid they realized what was
going on they didn't let them in so then
the Germans went back to thinking of
other methods of rescuing the hostages
they tried to find out if anybody had
ever developed any sort of sleeping gas
which could be used they rang the
Pentagon they rang the British but no
such gas exists so they then began
thinking okay we're going to have to
actually go in there and physically
rescue these Israelis and I'll if it's
ok then I'll read a little section in a
short while which I think really covers
and explains just how inept the German
response was just how they did
everything wrong it was a rescue
operation called Operation sunshine
where
realize basic elements of the rescue
operation would go completely haywire
so that was their initial their initial
rescue the the one with the chef's and
operation sunshine the day wore on and
gradually the German authorities the
German Olympic authorities anyway began
putting pressure on the local police to
resolve the matter one way or the other
the games had been stopped by that point
despite some of the Germans who wanted
it to contains to continue but the games
had finally been stopped because of
international pressure and the German or
German Olympic organizers really wanted
the games to start again one way or the
other they just wanted the problem
resolved I got the impression that they
didn't really care too much whether
there were lives lost they just wanted
the games to carry on and so the local
police who were in charge of this
operation decided to come up with a more
serious rescue plan and the crucial
thing here I think is that it was the
local police who were responsible for
this international incident I mean no
disrespect to the police of Baltimore
but if there was a siege in a similar
circumstances it wouldn't be up to the
local officers to resolve it there would
be federal officers brought in there
would be highly trained
counter-terrorist unit brought in to try
and save people's lives but the Germans
because of the the structure of Germany
as it was set up after the end of the
Second World War by the Allies they
didn't have anything like this it was
left just to the local authorities and
local officials to try and resolve this
and whenever the Israeli observers who
had arrived in Munich by that time
questioned this they were just so told
there's nothing we can do this is our
Constitution this is the way it has to
be so the Germans tried to come up with
a rescue plan they decided to deceive
the terrorists and tell them that they
were going to fly them out of the
Olympic Village and helicopters take
them to an airfield and then fly them
out to a safe haven in the middle east
what they were actually planning to do
was take everyone to the airfield just
outside Munich it was an airfield called
fürstenfeldbruck and then they were
going to launch a rescue operation there
using force with sniper
and with the shock troops who were
supposed to rush in and save the
Israelis it didn't go according to plan
late in the evening of that night the
siege had taken place throughout that
day then late in the evening the
hostages and the terrorists were flown
out of the Olympic Village and two
helicopters they were taken to this
airfield just a short distance outside
Munich and just as they were coming in
to land everything started to go wrong
with the German rescue operation
literally as these helicopters were
circling the apron ready to land 17
German police officers who were manning
a crucial position on the plane which
was supposed to fly the terrorists and
the hostages out of Germany these 17
German police officers voted amongst
themselves to abandon their position
they decided they were in too much
danger that they were crucial absolutely
crucial to the rescue operation and it
left the fact that they abandoned their
position left five German snipers to
tackle eight heavily armed fully
committed fanatical terrorists I mean I
call them snipers I mean they were in
name alone they didn't have the proper
training they didn't have the proper
rifles they didn't have they didn't have
flak jackets they didn't have helmets
walkie talkies infrared equipment sights
for the proper sites for their rifles
they had no training they had no
equipment they were all positioned
around the airfield several of them
didn't know where their comrades were
two of them were actually in the field
of fire of the of the other German
snipers it was a just a total farce as
the helicopters landed containing the
hostages and the terrorists they landed
on the apron to the terrorists got out
walked to the the aeroplanes supposed to
fly them out of the country they got on
board the airplane they discovered it
was completely empty because the the
police officers had abandoned their
positions realized it was a trap left of
the the plane and began running or
jogging back to the helicopters and that
was the crucial point at that point the
German snipers opened fire or at least
two of them did because the others
weren't in radio contact
one of them discovered he was in full
line of fire and there were bullets
whizzing around him
the Germans missed their main targets
one of the terrorists was hit in the leg
he limped back to the helicopters dived
underneath and a gun battle just erupted
after that I mean it was a farcical
situation the Germans were firing down
as if they were shooting pigeons with
their some of them had bolt-action
rifles and the terrorists had these were
Kalashnikov assault rifles I mean
they're a devastating weapon they threw
grenades they opened fire they swept the
airport buildings with bullets and a
German police officer was was hit in the
head and died immediately at that point
the all of the hostages were still alive
there were nine there at the airfield
and the eight terrorists the gun battle
went on quite it was quite intense gun
battle lasting for between half an hour
and 45 minutes and then it quieten down
a bit and nobody really seemed to know
what to do the Germans wouldn't go up to
the planes to the helicopters because
they were scared of being shot the
terrorists couldn't go anywhere because
they were surrounded to all intents and
purposes and the Israeli observers who
were there just started pleading with
the Germans what are you going to do
next what are you going to do to save
our to save our comrades and they say
that the Germans just said there's
there's nothing we can do what can we do
we don't know what to do anyway the
clock ticked on when you got to two
hours the gun batter was still erupting
sporadically and then finally some
German armored cars arrived on the scene
they'd been called in by the German
officials in the hope that they would be
able to get closer to the helicopters
without anybody being shot inside them
they trundled on these these armored
cars trundled on to the airport apron
and it was such a farcical situation
they actually thought that one of the
German snipers was one of the terrorists
and the armored car the German armored
car actually opened fire on their own
man they hit one of the snipers in the
buttocks they hit another one of the
German helicopter pilots in one of the
his lung and then at that point
the terrorists either apparently thought
they were about to be machine gun or
thought that was their last chance to
execute their hostages they turned their
guns on the Israelis in the back of the
helicopters and detonated a grenade
inside one of the choppers all of the
remaining nine Israeli hostages died at
that point they died on the air in full
view of all these German police officers
there were several hundred German
officers at the scene they could not
save a single Israeli who was there five
of the terrorists were killed three of
them survived and as I said one German
police officer was killed in several
injured but nine of the Israelis were
killed I mean I'm personally I'm I'm not
Jewish I'm not Israeli not Palestinian
I'm not an Arab for that matter but a
cadet anything you can fail to
appreciate or understand the scent the
scale of this tragedy every single one
of them was killed it was extraordinary
and there was a lot of soul-searching
afterwards I think among some of the
German officials who'd been present
because there was a lot of accusations
that maybe it was anti-semitism that was
responsible for this they hadn't been
prepared to fully commit to the rescue
operation because of some sort of
institutionalized hatred of Jews or a
xenophobic hatred of foreigners and I
think to some extent there might be some
truth in that because some some of the
Germans only really seem to be upset
about what was going on when the
helicopter pilots who've taken everyone
into the airfield were taken hostage as
well when their own comrades of another
Germans were held hostage
that was when they really seemed to get
angry about what was going on so that
was the the the essence of the tragedy I
mean I think in many ways it continued
for reasons that still aren't very clear
German officials at the outskirts of the
airfield then began telling people who
were were gathering around they're
journalists and sightseers but the
operation had been a complete success
but all of the Israelis had been had
been rescued alive and this news it
spread like like wildfire as you can
imagine Reuters the news agency pumped
it out around the world
Golda Meir was told about this she
cracked open a bottle of champagne
with some of her cabinet colleagues the
head the front page of The Jerusalem
Post the next morning at the headline
that all the all the hostages had been
saved and the truth didn't come out two
hours afterwards when all of the
relatives had been told about this and
most of them had started celebrating and
then gradually the truth came out that
some of the Israelis had been injured
then some of them had been killed and
then finally on American TV it was
broadcast by ABC and Jim McKay said just
the three words they're all gone they're
all gone you just kept repeating this
but it wasn't just the public you're
watching this obviously it was relatives
they they thought that their loved ones
were safe and then they had this news
over the the public TV networks that
they'd all died I mean absolute tragedy
for them in Israel I think this the the
tragedy of this was dis compounded by
the fact that they were initially told
everyone had been rescued Golda Meir was
absolutely furious as you can imagine
she ordered airstrikes in Lebanon on
Israeli Palestinian camps there in which
several scores are thought to have died
they also the Israeli Defense Forces the
IDF launched an armored raid into
southern Lebanon the largest since the
1967 war in which again many many
Palestinian fighters and also some
civilians died well that was really just
the beginning Golda felt that it was the
attack was so of such ferocity and so
barbaric almost you know to launch an
attack at the Olympic Games I mean
people felt that there there was some
sanctity there that it was somehow free
of international politics she was
furious about this and later she
authorized the launch of a more
coordinated targeted assassination
campaign which has since become known as
operation wrath of God she was really
encouraged to do this eventually when
the Germans released the three remaining
terrorists they'd taken prisoner at the
airfield as I said three survived the
attack five of them had been killed
three survived they were taken
and then they were released a few weeks
later when the Germans did a deal with a
separate Palestinian group the
Palestinians told them that unless they
released these three guys then the
Palestinians would launch attacks on
left-handed jets which are obviously the
German national air carrier because of
this the German authorities decided to
wash their hands of the problem finally
and just released the meat without even
telling the Israelis what they were
doing the three remaining terrorists
flew back to Libya and to a hero's
welcome really much of it was in full
support of what had happened it was only
really King Hussein of Jordan who
expressed any misgivings and committed
commiserated with the Israeli people so
that was really what encouraged Golder
to go to my ear to launch the the more
coordinated revenge operation was
unprecedented and she had quite a few
moral qualms about it not only because
it violated international law but also
because she was very worried about
putting Israeli agents in in the in
potential harm she feared some might be
captured or even killed while they were
launching these assassination raids but
it went ahead she was persuaded by their
officials that it was the only response
that really would turn the terror on the
terrorists that would stop these type of
terrorist attacks and so Israeli agents
were sent out with a brief to inflict
terror on the terrorists as I say they
put a landmine under a car seat of
somebody in Paris which practically
annihilated the the guy vaporized much
of his body they blew up somebody in
their bed in Cyprus they shot people in
the street and they even put a bomb
under a telephone of another suspect and
it was done in almost a judicial way the
Israelis now claim they say a dossier of
evidence was compiled on each individual
it was in forward to a committee which
is now known as committee X in I mean
it's difficult to know the exact truth
but that's what the Israeli officials
claim now is called committee X and it
basically gave a green or a red light to
each assassination and this went on from
for months and months
gradually the Palestinians began to
realize they were being targeted some of
the senior officials moved their
families to do Egypt into safe houses
and several of the terrorist attacks
that were believed of being planned were
actually canceled because some of the
militants were killed by the Israeli
term that's in that sense it was it was
seen in Israel as a great success but it
carried on it didn't stop it became
almost like an unstoppable mission
because once he Israeli started they
thought they could continue and they
could go after other members of the PLO
who they deemed to be a terrorist threat
or who would deemed to be likely to take
control of the PLO in the future because
of this I heard Barak who of course is
now Israeli prime minister who was then
in the early 70s he was the leader of
the Israeli equivalent of Delta Force or
the British SAS I suppose you could call
it an elite commando unit anyway I heard
Barak led a mission into Beirut to
execute three senior members of the PLO
who would need to be responsible for
Munich and other terrorist atrocities
and Barak went in there one of those one
of those incidents which seemed to the
dog the Middle East reallly as being
truth is stranger than fiction he went
in disguised as a woman with a wig and
grenades in a brought in his bra and he
had this some other dainty little
handbag as he describes it with the big
enough of plenty of explosives he went
in they him and his troops gathered
outside a sub-tree apartment blocks
which housed these senior Palestinians
they went in and assassinated them it
was very effective several other
civilians were killed but they got their
targets and the Israeli of the Lebanese
press began wondering about the
identities of these women carrying
disease this wielding death in the in
the streets of Beirut it was a fairly
extraordinary operation it's become
legendary and Israeli commando circles
and it had Barak obviously on the back
of that became this legendary commando
and
to lead the country so that was the that
was the initial revenge operations they
went on for many years after that that's
now quite difficult to establish exactly
what was in response for Munich and what
was a separate revenge operations
certainly even in in recent years
Israeli generals have suggested that
some mysterious killings have been
risking as a result of Munich the finals
of the settling of scores as it were for
this atrocity which really did have such
a powerful impact on Israel and I feel I
think amongst Jews around the world
certainly every Israeli I've spoken to
about this has said it really is a scar
on the on Israeli history modern history
because it really made Israelis feel yet
again that they were being targeted
around the world as the the Nazis had
come for them a few decades previously
now the Arabs were able to strike around
the world with virtual impunity and this
was this is what's been put forward as
the reasons for such a coordinated
revenge operation so hope that gives you
I mean obviously there's much life for
garden but I'm not speaking with notes
or cue cards or anything so I hope
you'll forgive me if I've missed out
certain important points what I was
going to do now if it's okay was just
explained briefly how I came to be
involved in this because as I say I'm
not not Jewish I'm not Palestinian for
that matter but I have written about
terrorism in the past and conducted
investigations into it both in America
and the Middle East and Northern Ireland
France and other countries and three
years ago I was talking to a film
producer who wanted to make a
documentary about the events in Munich
and he wanted a sort of investigative
journalist to help kick-start some of
the research and that's how really I
became involved there's a film of the
same name which as was said won the
Oscar for Best Documentary earlier this
year and I think was shown on HBO just a
few weeks or months ago I don't know if
anybody here saw it but I think it's
coming out again and will be released in
cinemas I think in some cinemas anyway
so that's really my background I hope if
if I have time that I can just read a
couple of sections which I think tell
part of the wider story
the first section I wanted to read the
short one just about just about the
relatives really I mean I think that in
many of the media coverage of terrorists
atrocities what's what gets forgotten is
that the people who died the victims are
all husbands fathers brothers mothers
etc they're individuals with families
and I think we really try to get across
in the book in the film the background
to each of the victims or at least
several of them and this is just a
section that relates the experiences of
of one of the families just in the very
early hours of the attack just as people
were becoming aware of what was going on
in Munich and I think really when when
talking about this I'd really appreciate
it if people could remember just the
symbolic importance of the fact that
these games were in Munich in Germany
just a few miles from Dachau and these
were these Israelis had gone there with
all the emotional all the memories all
the all the knowledge of what their
loved ones had suffered just a few years
previously and yet they'd still gone
there to confront this I mean it was
just awesome bravery even though many of
them said they felt terrified about
going back there but they really wanted
to show the Germans that the Nazis
hadn't won that the Jews could return
there and compete and win and do well
and show that Hitler hadn't achieved all
of his aims so anyway this is this is a
section that starts with just the the
fact that dozens of relatives experience
that same desperate fear on the morning
of September 5th in Israel in a
smattering of homes across the fledgling
state the horror was mixed with
disbelief not in Germany not Jews not
again relatives reacted differently to
the news some wanted to be surrounded by
friends and family others just wanted to
be alone with their thoughts miriam got
frightened the wife of Yosef the
wrestling referee walked to the Western
Wall in Jerusalem to pray Judith the
couple's daughter dismissed the gossip
of schoolmates that her father had been
killed
he's too big to be killed she retorted
and rushed home to take news reports for
her father to enjoy when he returned
Elana Romano young why
the weightlifter Yosef was asleep in bed
when she was awakened by a pounding on
her door at around 9 a.m. a neighbor had
been listening to the radio and was the
first to break the appalling news alana
recalls I turned on the radio and I
heard that a group of terrorists that
entered the Olympic Village they've
murdered an athlete and taken hostages
the young woman was thrown into
hysterics a terror made worse perhaps
because she had not wanted her husband
to travel to Munich at all throughout
his training for the Olympic Games I had
fears she said very bad feeling the
closer we got to the Olympics I said
Yossi you know what I'm very afraid
Joseph would simply turn to her a broad
smile creasing his face and say Ilana
come on stop it don't put pressure on
yourself the Germans they think about
everything nothing will happen don't
worry but Ilana did worry every time
you're safe left the house to train for
the competition like other wives of
members of the Israeli delegation Ilana
was a young woman struggling to bring up
the couple's children while her husband
built up his muscles the two of them had
met on the beach
yosef romano was a local superhero all
brawn and muscle brought a muscle
coupled with a winning personality he
was very strong she said he had this
smile on his face he always had a smile
on his face when I first saw him I said
wow and when he first opened his mouth
he was so gentle it was so easy to fall
in love with the man their marriage
still came as something of a surprise
her parents were about to emigrate from
Israel to Italy and a liner and out she
wanted to stay behind no way you're not
going to stay here by yourself said her
parents what are you talking about we're
getting married you have told them
indignantly I didn't even have time to
think the cause Ilana
it was simple true love she married a
sports fanatic
well Ilana was giving birth to their
first child Joseph was away pumping iron
at a competition he used to promise me
that this competition would be the last
she says with a wry smile but then came
the Olympics Joseph had trained hard but
he was no match for the top athletes and
nations many times larger than tiny
Israel enjoyed his competitions but on
September 3rd Joseph rang Alana from
Munich to tell her he had injured
himself and will be returning home in
two
aid with one of the team doctors for an
operation on his leg don't worry he said
everything's fine I miss you how are the
children I want to come back home and
that says Alana was his last telephone
call it was very moving Alana didn't
hear from Yossef the next day and on the
fifth she expected a telegram or a call
that letter no when he would be home
instead the news from Munich came via
her neighbor the Israeli building had
been invaded
I rang at the Olympic Committee in
hysterics and asked what had happened
she recalls they told her not to panic
but when an official mentioned the
attack had started several hours earlier
Alana became even more frightened four
or five hours later and Yossi didn't
call she remembers thinking it didn't
seem reasonable Yossi didn't call and
Yossi knows that I worry Elana
instinctively knew something terrible
had happened she made desperate calls to
friends and officials within Israel but
nobody seemed to know what was going on
in Munich then finally she heard on the
news that Yosef had been one of the
hostages and her world fell apart I
understood your Sif's she said I knew
his character he wouldn't be treated
like cattle he would do something
I was worried his chances were slim and
the devil inside me told me there was no
chance I found that very poignant
because some she really seemed to know
even with hindsight she really seemed to
know that something terrible had
happened then and it had by that point
by the time she was awake her love
beloved husband had already been killed
he was the one left in the middle of the
room with the rest of the hostages as
the warning to them what would happen if
they dared to escape and she really
seemed to have a premonition and seemed
to know that that was that was what had
happened so the other pet section I was
just hoping to read which in a way it's
is equally depressing I think just
relates to the German rescue operation
that I mentioned earlier called
operation sunshine which was something
they launched later in the afternoon
when they realized they'd have to use
force and they decided to go in and try
and rescue the Israelis excuse me
my throat's dry I'm sorry it's based on
an interview with a German police
officer I hope you can bear with me
because it's translated from German and
we try to keep it as a truthful to what
he said it's possible it's a little bit
stilted but we didn't want to be accused
of manipulating anything he said it to
its place as I say on this this sole
German officer we did the film crew the
film researchers and myself we all tried
to locate more Germans who'd been
involved German police studies but this
was the only guy who would talk to us
all the others were actually threatened
with losing their pension rights if they
agree if they actually spoke to us which
personally I've never heard of this
happening before and I certainly can't
imagine it happening in Britain or
America the idea that officials would
threaten people with losing their
pensions if they spoke to journalists is
I think pretty extraordinary this was
the only police officer who'd speak to
us and he would only talk because he'd
already lost his pension because he had
a row or something with his Union anyway
I think he's a very credible witness he
was there and I think what he says I
found what he had to say very
interesting
his name's hind so Henson and I'll just
relate what he says Heinze Henson a 30
year old police superintendent detective
is he but it was one of the officers
charged with launching the assault a
senior member of the Special Search
Group more used to fighting organized
crime the Henson had been at Connelly
strata which was where the Israeli
building was for about 7 a.m. he recalls
we that is the special search group were
considered to be the best qualified unit
to solve the issue because we were
trained in hand-to-hand combat together
with 12 colleagues from his group Henson
climbed up onto the roof or joining and
above 31 Connelly Strasse in preparation
for the assault which was given the
optimistic codename operation sunshine
where we were equipped he says with
training suits armored vests machine
guns and our regular revolvers and the
aim of the action was to attack after
getting the keyword sunshine announced
by the inspector then we would have to
enter the ventilation shafts and free
the hostages
we'd already unscrewed the covers of the
shafts the team had spent several hours
obtaining and then studying the plans of
the building but he says we didn't know
about the exact position of the
terrorists in the burning we had plans
about the position of the shafts we knew
where to come out down there but we
wouldn't know the position of the enemy
until the final moment o Henson and the
other officers were deeply skeptical
about their chances of success the men
had agreed he says to do whatever we
could to save the Israelis the
completely innocent athletes and to
minimize the amount of bloodshed but he
believes it would surely been a suicide
mission for us Peter Jennings of ABC
television remembers watching from the
balcony of the Italian delegation
opposite the Israeli building as the
Germans moved into place I remember he
says when the Germans looked like they
were going to bring a commando team in
and try to get in 231 from the top I
remember feeling very strongly that's my
end badly it was an extremely tense
period thousands of spectators watching
the police from a hillock just outside
the perimeter fence were growing
agitated some began shouting their
support for the officers while others
were heard yelling tactical advice as if
they were watching a sports event and
when I say I say sports event in the
book but I mean it was more like they
were watching a pantomime to be honest
by this point there are about 80,000
spectators and sightseers standing
around outside the fence looking into
the Olympic Village many of them had
been at the sports events and had just
begun milling around outside when the
sports events were cancelled because of
this seed but they just really many I
mean most of them were German and they
didn't really seem to view it as the
tragedy that we view it as now they were
yelling things out to the police
officers like get down get down look out
behind you and things like this as if it
was sort of a theatre or something
there were people eating hot dogs from
frankfurters there were vendors walking
amongst the crowd selling lollipops in
the shape of the Olympic mascot with
children running around getting
autographs and things like this and I've
actually heard them tape recordings that
were made by people in the crowd just of
what other people were saying around
them and you can really hear
these Germans talking and using the most
extraordinary anti-semitic language
about what was going on in thinking that
nobody was overhearing them I mean it
really does beg your belief here were
these games the Germans thought we're
going to portray them in a new light and
you sort of scratch the surface with
this type of attack and all the old
prejudices were coming out anyway so
most of those Germans were viewing as
some sort of pantomime but pressed up
against the the fence surrounding the
Olympic Village I'll carry on pressed
against a fence a tearful group of young
Jewish protesters were holding banners
decrying the hostage-taking they began
singing we shall overcome and Israeli
national anthem but there are also many
more spectators watching the police
prepare their assault dozens of
television crews had their cameras
trained on the policemen they had
exactly the right angle to film us
standing there ready ready to storm the
building said hind so handsome
finally a German commander realized that
television viewers could see the police
team moving into place and averted a
disaster we waited and waited on the
roof of course Herr Henson but the code
word wasn't given because as we found
out later on the building of the
venniese German team which was sort of
opposite the Israelis there was a camera
team that was filming and broadcasting
live the events on the roof including
how we were standing there I think all
we already removed the ventilation shaft
covers ready to enter the building to
start the attack the terrorists had also
been watching events unfolding around
them ISA he was the terrorist leader
stop planning how his men would fly out
of the country and was seen scanning the
roof while the head of another terrorist
kept appearing out of window below her
Hansen the check if any officers could
be seen
ISA ran downstairs to the front door and
screamed at the German officials outside
the lesser police were withdrawn
immediately he would personally execute
two of the hostages later says hein so
Henson we discovered they had been a TV
in each of the athletes rooms and the
terrorists had been able to follow the
events on the roof live on screen the
pictures had been broadcast all over the
world including my home where my wife
had been watching me anxiously
sitting and climbing onto the roof so I
think I hope that gives you some idea of
the nature of the German response they
had no idea what they were doing they
didn't even begin to think that they did
install television sets in every single
room in the Olympic Village and they
didn't they hadn't thought the the
terrorists would have the sense to be
watching what was going on was
absolutely extraordinary and I hope also
that that gets across one of the central
themes that I'm trying to put forward in
the book which is really that it was
German obviously more responsibility for
the attack must lie with the terrorists
but responsibility I think must also lie
with the German authorities for their
inept handling of the siege and the
rescue operation and I think that's
partly reflected in the fact that
Germany German officials tried to cover
up the precise sequence of events for
nearly 25 years it was only through -
only through the real persistence of
some of the relatives that the German
officials finally in revealed and
admitted that they had 4,000 nearly
4,000 files relating to this tragedy
that they've kept hidden until just a
few years ago they just lied to the
relatives and told them they didn't
exist partly I think because they didn't
want to be accused of anti-semitism in
their handling of the rescue but also
perhaps because they didn't want to be
exposed to allegations of incompetence
which I think are now pretty pretty
clear quite frankly so if that's okay I
was going to then just see if anybody
had any comments or questions or
thoughts
there's one of the one of the territory
were involved in the actual attack which
was by a group called Black September
which was a faction of the PLO one of
those terrorists survives two of them
let me start again three of them
survived the attack two were then traced
and executed I we understand by Israeli
agents and one survives to this day he
still lives in hiding we've traced him
for the the book in the film and he was
so still so scared he would only be
interviewed in in shadow and obviously
we don't fully know where he's living
now several other senior PLO officials I
suppose could be deemed responsible or
or have some responsibility for the
attack certain Yasser Arafat was head of
the PLO at the time and other
Palestinian officials have suggested
quite clearly that he knew the bed
details of what what was being planned
there's also another several other more
June slightly more junior officials who
were still alive and well we believe
they weren't executed or trace and
executed by Israelis because they later
became more opposed to terrorism if you
like and Mossad saw them as less
threatening to the the State of Israel
than other Palestinian leaders so there
was that sense that they were kept alive
because it was it was better the devil
that Israel knew than then it didn't
to do it themselves and the Israelis
probably would have been successful they
were successful in the past
absolutely Cindy yeah yeah it's a very
good point because Golda did offer she
did say to the Germans we have a
commanding we have a counter-terrorist
unit who are trained for this
why won't maybe they could come to
Germany and launch the rescue operation
but the Germans refused largely because
of their federal structure because of
the way Germany was established at the
end of the Second World War they refused
to accept them they said we can't do
that it has to be the responsibility of
Germans to handle this there were
commandos who are actually on the plane
ready to go and then go in and do this
and I think the Israelis perhaps the
Russians and the British were the only
real countries that had the terrorist
Counter Terrorist expertise to handle
this I mean perhaps it is easy to say in
hindsight Germany handled this generally
handled this so spectacularly badly but
in honestly there are many countries
that wouldn't have been able to launch a
rescue operation because they didn't
have the expertise and indeed many
countries set up an established
counter-terrorist unit precisely because
of what happened in Munich possibly I
think it's unlikely that there wouldn't
have been fatalities quite frankly
because of the terrorists were totally
committed but there were I mean there
were ways that the chairman's could have
done things differently which may have
resulted in several of the Israelis
being saved I mean there was the head of
Mossad was actually at the airfield he
was there as an observer he had to train
another Israeli as a translator but he
was there and he he I got the impression
that he'd almost shaken one of the
German officials when the battle had
started and said to them what are you
going to do next what will you do now
you have to rush in there you have to
rush in from all sides as as Israeli
commandos tend to do and then hopefully
we can save some of these these hostages
but the Germans I mean they weren't
trained they weren't prepared to do that
at all
no absolutely
listen I know if the terrorists gain
anything by this whole episode well I
suppose that depends on your perspective
really in many ways many commentators
Israeli and otherwise have suggested
that the attack was a spectacular
success in the sense that prior to it
many people around the world didn't know
even though Palestinians existed
afterwards 900 million people around the
world saw this attack on television it
was a unique terrorist attack and after
it the whole world knew that there were
these people called Palestinians and
that they would resort to terrorist
atrocities to get their voices heard was
it a success in in the sense I think it
made Palestinians portrayed and in the
minds of the world it linked them
forever with terrorism so it did them a
terrible disservice in that sense but it
also made it also made many countries
feel that they had to open negotiations
and diplomatic links with the PLO for
fear that terrorist attacks would be
launched on their soil so it's difficult
to say I mean I personally don't think
terrorism has ever worked but then I
also don't think violence over words
obviously you can see throughout history
where terrorism has been used by people
who some seeds freedom fighters and some
see you some seeds psychopathic
murderers we can see with the founding
of Israel that some of the tactics that
we use then some people have described
that as terrorism I mean where where do
we draw the line it's difficult to say
but certainly in this incident I think
it was a terrible tragedy for all all
concerned
it's a very good question because some
as I thought I felt this was again
another element of the tragedy because
the Israeli officials had been told by
the Germans but they didn't need to send
armed security personnel because the
Germans would look after the Israelis
would look after the Jews and more than
anyone more than any race on earth the
Jews knew the the the officious
efficient nature of Germany and of
Germans and they really believed this
the Spanish are believed to have sent
armed guards to protect their king who
was competing in the sailing but Israel
didn't didn't send armed officials
several of the Israelis were were
classed as security guards or they had a
security function but there was no
official security delegation and the
Israelis were just housed in regular
accommodation like the like other
countries although several Israeli
officials later claimed they requested
the Israelis be put in separate
accommodation and guarded but it does
they don't seem to have pushed that
enough and the Germans didn't recognize
the danger basically despite their there
were many warnings before the Olympics
that they were Palestinian terrorists on
the move in in continental Europe and
that an attack was planned in some way
but they just didn't seem to take heed
of them they start they kept going
initially the German officials were very
reluctant to stop them and indeed Avery
Brundage she was then head of the into
the head of the International Olympic
Committee he'd also been head during the
1936 Berlin Olympics which had obviously
been used to glorify Nazi ideology and
he was in many ways quite anti-semitic
he said that the games must go on during
the day of the siege they'd been stopped
but only after an outcry around the
world not just from Israel but from
other countries and they were then
started I think it's fair to say with
pretty indecent haste after the after
the final massacre there was a the next
morning just within about 4-6 hours
really of the of the tragedy the
airfield there was a memorial service
and then the games restarted as as if
nothing had happened really many
athletes refused to compete they were so
devastated but others wanted the games
to continue and it has to be said the
head of the Israeli delegation at the
time also felt that the game should go
on because he felt as did many Israeli
other Israeli officials that if they'd
been stopped and then terrorism had won
that it was giving in and he felt that
they should continue others obviously
obviously would disagree yes sorry the
Israeli agents other well many of them
are is interesting we only we only know
the backgrounds of some of them and we
know the backgrounds of some of them
largely because they were arrested in a
in a quite a tragic incident when his
Raley agent shot the the wrong person in
Norway they thought they were shooting
the the future head of the PLO and they
actually shot a Moroccan waiter who was
walking home from the cinema with his
pregnant wife many of them were arrested
at that point and it became clear that
some of them were they were just regular
civilian who had been brought in to the
assassination campaigns at the last
minute they were jailed and then they
were released and they now live still in
in the Scandinavia and in in Israel the
senior Israeli agent was decorated and
went on for to have a long career with
Mossad and then was accused of helping
general Noriega in Panama bizarrely
yes re-sod Herman who to go away after
and did they consider going after our
fat I think they did at some point but
um I mean there's certainly cases when
Mossad agents are supposed to
had arafat literally in there in their
rifle sites and there's a story which i
don't entirely know if it's true to be
honest but the CIA was said to have been
given photographs taken by israeli
agents through a sniper scope showing to
prove to the CIA they could have killed
him if they'd wanted to they don't they
didn't go after arafat as a result of
this and they seem to have gone after
people who were directly linked with the
munich and then people that they felt
were a potential future threat to israel
who they could link with munich in some
way so there was almost a a moral
justification for assassinating them
because they could be described in
off-the-record briefings as being as
being linked in some way with munich or
in some way with the controlling
structure of Black September which was
essentially part of the PLO but just had
plausible deniability
so the PLO leadership could say oh no
these terrorist attacks aren't anything
to do with us they're this other group
like September they don't seem to have
gone after the families they just went
after the individuals really in in the
coordinated targeted operations when
they launched in the immediate aftermath
of Munich they launched these airstrikes
on in Lebanon and they launched this
armored thrust into Lebanon where they
destroyed houses of suspected militants
but I'm surprised this is still going on
to be honest because some and I spoken
to people in Mossad and army
intelligence from that period who
recognized this was a terrible mistake
by Israel because with every attack that
was launched every house that was
destroyed you had three or four more
militants joining them and joining
militant sections of the PLO and being
prepared to take part in terrorist
actions so in that sense it was seen as
a failure of the revenge operations
because it just encouraged hundreds
literally hundreds of hundreds more
terrorists to join up yes sir
repercussions or the 17 police officers
that left the aircraft no as far as
we're aware not a single German official
at all was even given a ticking off
it said it already doesn't yes sorry
with such a bad history how come the
Palestinians have managed to woo most of
the world with their nonsense on
television what now or then now it's
difficult to say I mean I'm no expert on
their beliefs to be quite frank with you
I know a fair bit about terrorism but I
think you know the world sees the
pictures maybe the Palestinians have
better PR officers that's been put
forward by some Israelis as an
explanation certainly people seem to be
forgetting the the Holocaust don't they
in recent years and more focuses come on
to the the the direct conflict between
them Israel and the Palestinians but
certainly I mean when you have the
imagery of the little boy who was shot
you know in his in his father's arms
that's very powerful and people always
go for these instant images for them
rather than looking at the background to
these events only they don't place it in
context you just get this 15 seconds
soundbite or 15 second bit of footage on
on the on the networks I don't know in
all honesty I can't really answer that
but I think I think there's an
understanding particularly you know in
Europe to some extent in North America
that the input the it's a much more
complicated situation than the the media
would have us believe that it
that's not
you've never been invited you get this
kind of mixer in an Arab neighborhood
say in Chicago or some no no but having
said that I mean there's I've we've been
traveling around the state and we have
done a lot of talks to communities which
aren't where there hasn't been a single
member the Jewish community there so
there is their secular interest in the
sense from from people who recognize
this as a tragedy and certainly in
England I've given talks to on this and
try to explain why this is why this was
such a tragedy for the Israelis two
communities of people who were more
pro-palestinian than than they have been
every in the States if you see what I
mean
and I think there is though I genuinely
think there is a recognition that this
was a this was a tragedy but you don't
have to be Jewish to realize that people
really suffered as a result of this that
families were torn to pieces and even if
you don't look at it from a political
angle you can see this the human
suffering that was involved in this of
families who had just ripped to pieces
by the loss of a son or a father or a
brother as I say I mean there were
families where a grandmother committed
suicide by setting herself on fire after
this she was just so devastated where
there was the son who died was the sole
surviving member of the family of a
family that survived the Holocaust and
then the one member of the generation
who of the family who was supposed to
carried on was killed in Munich you
can't fail to be affected by the scale
of the tragedy whatever your background
I would hope and sorry adeno of Mossad
continues to seek out the one remaining
I don't think so I don't think they and
we wait it's nearly 30 years later I
mean certainly Israel has a long arm and
an even longer memory but I think if
they really wanted to get him by now
they would have done as I said I mean
even in recent years though four or five
years ago there were some mysterious
deaths which it see there was some
suggestion that it was linked with
Munich but I think it was more likely it
was a at the time it was a pre-election
ploy and there was some political
machinations going on
we're by generals put forward the
suggestion it was it was for Munich
almost a bomb almost a bolster the the
military image of Israel at the time I
don't think they'd go after him in in
summary and to be honest I think they
have a tough job finding him because
some he's he's well hidden and he's
terrified he hasn't made the mistakes
that some of the other terrorists made
which was to link up with some of their
families in abroad in the Gulf region
and that was what led to their then
being traced and executed well you think
so here certainly I'm under so
journalist but we found him because we
were prepared to let a Palestinian crew
film him
I spoke them but you wouldn't actually
meet anyone that he didn't know and he's
kept to that apparently he's kept to
that throughout the last thirty years
and that's kept him alive I didn't do it
in through no Palestinian crew did it I
was the only way he could get to speak
to him was by agreeing to that I mean
we've had I think quite understandably
although the film was made one of the
producers of the film was at a firm
Zionist and one of his family a very
prominent in the creation of Israel he
felt that we really had to get
terrorists to talk as well really to
just to prove that it was an independent
assessment of what happened doesn't
detract from the evil that was committed
there but it really does make it it
proves to the world that we've got every
aspect of this that we possibly could
we've got you know the victims the
relatives the the Israeli side we've got
the the sole surviving member of the
terrorist unit and also we've got
finally all this German evidence that
the German officials tried to hide for
25 years and I hope I mean I obviously
would have made mistakes in what we did
but I hope we've got a pretty definitive
account of what happened and the full
scale of the tragedy for the for the
victims
for me oh really I mean you do really
more when you're doing things on
organized crime and things like that
than with this because I think I've
tried to be pretty balanced in
approaching this I think anybody who
reads the book or sees the film will
realize it was an absolute tragedy but
this
I've got no political real political
views and I'm trying to put forward it's
just really the the fact that it was I
keep using this word but it was a very
sad tragic event so I don't feel that
I'm making a political point necessarily
and I don't think any I mean what I've
had death threats as a result of this
but I've had many more on doing other
subjects okay yeah but I mean you do I
mean see it's just gauging how serious
they are when you get them from German
officials and as much as from anyone
else I would imagine we're responsible
for some of these okay start up signing
up straight thank you all very much for
coming it's so quite um flattering to
see such a large crowd here thank you
very much indeed what you want me to do